[Musique]
et donc c'est avec vous à Tiz barré ce
soir du coup on a été rejoint par Léo un
petit chat un petit chat un petit Léo un
petit chat de 2 ans donc aujourd'hui
j'ai mis ma blouse et puis je suis en
compagnie de notre petit Léo qui est là
je le remercie d'être devenu là sous les
lumières pour parler donc du vaccin la
vaccination qui est très importante pour
protéger donc nos amis les chats de
maladie qui peuvent être graves très
graves et même mortel alors quels sont
ces maladies Athis alors il y a
plusieurs maladies on va commencer
d'abord
qui est une maladie virale et
contagieuse
oui les tailles patients alors
donc les signes cliniques donc ce sont
les éternuesments les écoulements au
niveau donc
écoulement nasaux au niveau
oculaire il y a également une fatigue
générale de l'animal si vous ne faites
pas vacciner une de la fièvre avec
une baisse de l'appétit c'est pas la
maladie la plus répandue au niveau des
chats notamment des Chats Sauvages oui
oui fait partie des maladies c'est pour
ça que je l'ai cité en premier ouais
c'est une maladie vraiment très virale
donc c'est très important de faire
vacciner son chat
renouveler tous les ans ou alors c'est
un vaccin oui des rappels à effectuer je
vais l'expliquer à peu près par la suite
j'ai eu des rappels qui sont à faire et
donc il y a d'autres maladies dont c'est
important de faire vacciner son chat
vous avez aussi le typhus qui est une
maladie qui est contagieuse et ce virus
en fait il est très résistant dans
l'environnement et il va être très
mortel pour les chatons parce qu'en fait
c'est une maladie qui va provoquer des
vomissements qui va vous provoquer la
diarrhée les chatons vont être très
affaiblis et ça va conduire
maladie mortelle vous avez également la
locomose la loco c'est une maladie
virale qui se transmet par la salive
donc les chats partageant une même
gamelle d'eau vont se transmettre la
maladie par le sang quand ils vont se
bagarrer en période de chaleur et autres
la maladie peut se transmettre et même
si votre chat ne sort pas il peut se la
maladie peut se transmettre par le biais
de la maman à son enfant donc le chat il
peut être assez automatique ne
présentait aucun signe au départ et puis
une fois que les signes vont commencer à
se présenter ça va se renouveler sans
cesse alors justement à quelle fréquence
faut-il faire ses vaccins à this alors
c'est vaccins là donc ils sont à
effectuer donc le premier vaccin est à
faire à partir de deux mois et demi et
ensuite c'est toutes les quatre semaines
jusqu'à au sixième mois de animal et
après on renouvelle on fait les rappels
jusqu'au 1 an de l'animal c'est dans les
premières premiers mois justement qui
sont le plus susceptibles d'attraper ces
maladies à partir de alors deux mois et
demi pourquoi parce qu'en fait le chat
n'est plus à l'été par la maman donc il
n'est plus protégé par par l'allaitement
et donc après donc pour renouveler et il
y a également une maladie qui est très
mortelle la rage donc la maladie commune
entre le chien et le chat cette maladie
se transmet à l'homme elle est très
mortelle elle va jouer sur les troubles
comportementaux et c'est un vaccin qui
est obligatoire quand vous partez
également à l'étranger on va vous
demander ce vaccin là et également sur
les lieux de vacances on vous demande
bien de présenter le vaccin contre la
rage et alors si jamais on n'est pas à
jour dans ces vaccins à qui c'est ce que
c'est grave est-ce que c'est dangereux
est-ce qu'on peut rattraper son retard
oui alors on ne s'inquiète pas on
s'inquiète un petit peu quand même
t'inquiète pas on reprend les vaccins
dès le départ bien sûr on consulte tout
le temps
vétérinaire c'est lui qui va installer
le protocole en fonction de l'âge de
l'animal de son mode de vie comme on dit
on habite chez son chat c'est pas lui
qui habite chez nous mais c'est nous qui
habitons chez notre chat et alors même
si on a un chat d'intérieur qui ne sort
jamais c'est important quand même de
faire ses vaccins oui c'est très
important les gens ont souvent posé la
question mon chat ne sort pas mais vous
vous pouvez être porteur de maladies
avec vos vêtements vos chaussures vous
allez faire du théâtre vous allez mettre
différents déguisements vous avez côtoyé
plein de personnes vous avez plein de
costumes vous allez porter des maladies
avec vous bien merci beaucoup à tous
barré pour toutes ces précisions on vous
retrouve bientôt pour une prochaine
chronique oui très bientôt pour préparer
l'été il fait très chaud pour nos
animaux et bien merci beaucoup à tous